in 2009 a screening was held this
audience was the first to experience a
new horror phenomenon what they saw left
them bored really really bore our normal
activity get ready to experience the
cheaper less interesting version of The
Blair Witch Project
behold the terror of a film so easy
anyone's dad could have shot and Suchi
it's created a genre of handheld crap
prepare to be terrified by a marketing
department so effective they actually
made cities demand this tedious whole
movie that substitutes shaky camera work
for legitimate horror with the premise
that they'll milk for at least five more
movies a movie for not in so gullible
they think that a moving sheet is scary
featuring a guy that can't stop acting
like a total douchebag who plans to
fight an invisible demon by yelling at
it
and a less-hot Katy Perry who basically
just cries a lot together they will
confront the terrifying question of why
he's filming so much put the camera away
and you and your stupid camera or the
problem maybe we shouldn't have the
camera yep turn on camera you stop
following a shocking tale where
characters point out what's scary doors
walk through an empty house in sleep for
like 60% of the movie with a mystery so
deep you'll be constantly asking
is she hot or is it just her big boobs
brace yourself for 86 minutes of a
guitar a door a fridge some empty rooms
a ceiling great a chandelier some blinds
and attic door stairs stairs stairs
stairs Juliet from lost and stares story
no one activity now guess I'll go see
this one this Halloween nothing else is
going maybe we should friend each other
on Facebook then links in the doobly-doo
as per the huge leave a comment telling
us what movie you'd like to see get the
honors treatment next and leave a quote
you'd like to hear me say next time in
my epic trailer voice it's peanut butter
jelly time
ermahgerd when you Gotham City is in
ashes you will have my permission to die
it'sa me Mario happy birthday Sarah
marry me